[موسيقى]
منصح مريض ارتفاع ضغط الدم ان هو يبتعد
خالص عن الاملاح عن المخللات
وعن عرق الصوص لان الاغذيه دي بتسبب في
ارتفاع ضغط الدم بننصحه انه ياكل خضار
وفاكهه اللي فيها نسبه عاليه من
البوتاسيوم لان البوتاسيوم بيبطل ضربات
القلب
وبيقلل من ارتفاع ضغط الدم لو مريض الكسور
الشريان التاجي مركب دعامه بقى له اكتر من
سنه او عمل عمليه قلب مفتوح بقى له اكتر
من سنه فده مسموح له ان هو يقدر يصوم
وبندي له بعض الارشادات منها ان هو لو كان
مدخن يمتنع تماما عن التدخين ويستغله ان
هو فرصه صيام شهر رمضان ان هو يكمل بعد
كده ما يدخلش بيمتنع عن الاغذيه اللي فيها
كوليسترول والاغذيه الدسمه والمقليات
وبننصحه ان هو ياكل اكثر اطعمه فيها اطعمه
شويه او المسلوقه من المهم جدا ان انا لما
اجي
في وقت الفطار اكثر الصيام ابتدي
بعصير او زبادي او تمر وبعد كده اقدر اخد
الادويه ما اخدش الادويه على معده فاضيه
[موسيقى]
لما انا بكون عندي ارتفاع في ضغط الدم او
قصور فوشيال التاجي اقدر ادي بعض النصائح
للمريض ازاي يقدر يصوم بطريقه سليمه وهي
ان هو يروح يشوف عنده دكتور طبيعي القلب
يقدر يغير له العلاج ويخليه ياخدوه في
المواعيد المناسبه قبل الصخور او بعض
الفطار بيقدر يستبدل الادويه اللي بيبقى
مفعولها قصير اقل من ثمان ساعات بادويه
اخرى مفعولها طويل بيغطي فتره الصيام
المده اكثر من 15 ساعه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات